the biggest block in Parliament in Iraq
has just nominated Assad a live nanny as
the next Iraqi Prime Minister live -
dorset Jabari in Baghdad Forrester saw
an appointment that's been a long time
coming who is a solid nanny and will his
nomination satisfy protesters well it is
very unlikely that this nomination will
go down well here he is the governor of
Basra province which is technically the
richest province in Iraq because it has
the most oil in all of the country but
it is actually one of the poorest where
the infrastructure is very very dire and
the protests that have started
ambassador I've been ongoing for many
months this governor has been accused of
not only corruption but also not paying
enough attention to try and remedy the
situation in his own province he is a
educated investor himself he comes from
one of the largest tribes in that
province his nomination is seeing as
again an influence by Iran in this
country because he's been nominated by
one of the biggest blocks in the
parliament Alvina block and it is
believed that this nomination comes with
the full backing and support of the
Iranian aligned groups in Iraqi politics
so protesters not likely to be happy
with this and other demonstrations going
to continue therefore certainly and what
little good news we had about the new
electoral laws that were passed on
Tuesday evening that were making these
demonstrators quite happy this morning
will now be all reversed based on this
decision this will just show that their
position has to go on the demonstrators
have to continue because this decision
shows that they are not a part of their
own political process that they're
choosing of the prime minister is not up
to the iraqi people but rather the
Parliament and the largest blocks there
and this is a point of contention and
the cause of all the demonstrations that
we've seen and the number of deaths that
are now at over 485 it is
because they want to be able to choose
our high minister and this nomination
will certainly add to the anger and
frustration that has been present here
thank you for that dosage a Bari with
the latest from Baghdad where again the
biggest parliamentary bloc has nominated
Assad al Adani
as the next iraqi prime minister